this is my favorite character in
jiu-jitsu kaisen
right now i'm sorry remember how i
teased on inumaki analysis at the end of
novara's video this guy here
is known for speaking his favorite
onigiri
ingredients well turns out it's actually
really hard to analyze a character based
on just that
that poor guy so instead i'm gonna
analyze a character that i think is
so well written and has such a fantastic
character art that you know
she's one of akutami's absolute
favorites
you see what makes maki so fun is that
she was treated like a dreadful
case of bad breath by her family but
rather than begging for acknowledgement
or affection
maki has decided to tear the whole
abusive zayn family to the grounds
of course this video will also be about
mai because as you will see
both of them are basically one character
split into
two there is a ton of symbolism around
the concept of twins here after all and
the story behind maki and mai is as
tragic as it is heartbreaking and so
it's no big surprise that it is her
sister who is maki's
biggest flaw and weakness as a character
at the same time however she also has
emerged from her past as incredibly
strong and fierce i've already focused
heavily on female writing in nobody's
video so i'll not
force the point again here but it
absolutely goes without saying that
maki is exceptionally well written for
shonen standards
and i think in contrary to the beliefs
of at least
some people in the industry having
self-confident badasses like kugisaki
and maki
makes everyone enjoy this story a lot
more
because as the manga readers will know
maki is here to stay and her character
only gets better and better this is the
story
of zayn mackey
it's maki's self-confident and
indifferent attitude as well as her
power in physical combat that
make it really easy to like her as a
matter of fact she represents
a lot of the most common shonen tropes
that we like to see in our heroes
a tragic past power in combat a
seemingly
unattainable goal they want to reach an
iron determination to fight for that
goal as well as the ability to stick
through the toughest moments
you fight with the strength of many men
tonight
we see her fiercely and fearlessly
wielding a whole arsenal of cursed
weapons no matter how strong the
opponent she's facing and so i think
maki is so extremely likable because she
basically has all the characteristics
that our usual shonen hero has
only as a badass girl and supporting
characters to put this into perspective
she doesn't share any of the external
struggles and vulnerabilities that make
itadori so special and
does make it extremely easy to latch
onto her
something we for example see someone
like nobody this is someone
that stands up against the men who have
suppressed her entire life and fights
for becoming a powerful woman that can
lead the clan herself
basically her dream is showing everyone
that looked down on her
one big middle finger
so it's very easy to see what makes her
so extremely cool to watch and follow
other than megumi who internalizes the
pain caused by his family situation
maki displays her emotional damage
openly to the world
and yet i believe that the reasons maki
stands out as a character
as with any great character are the
underlying flaws
unseen symbols and steady character
progressions that happen beneath her
straightforward feeling surface
and gigiakutami sure went full out
when crafting her character
were born as twin sisters to the
powerful zane clan
the most powerful family in the jewish
two worlds
if it weren't for this guy right here
who basically carries the gojo family on
his own and as a result
maki's and my story isn't only dramatic
and sad in one way but
rather akutami has piled a whole
mountain of dramatic layers
on top of both of them that weighs down
heavily on their lives you know
just as american breakfast does first of
all there is the fact that the juju 2
world
operates based on very traditional and
conservative japanese rules
born into a powerful family you're
expected to always put the clan's
interests
first you have to be strong and flawless
serve your elders and bring no
shame onto the family name in other
words there is no room for
personal feelings and ambitions on top
of this
big surprise in this conservative combat
oriented and patriarchal family
structure
being born as a girl puts you on a harsh
disadvantage
right from the start you neither have
the same social standing nor the same
base physical strength of the male
family members
and so every woman has to work at least
twice as hard
to be recognized as a full-fledged
sorcerer
then there is the fact that maki and mai
are
twins which for a long time were seen as
a sign of misfortune in japan
i even found this very interesting study
that details different types of food
that pregnant japanese women were
supposed to avoid
to not bear twins such as twin chestnuts
double section tangerines or double
eggplants
thus being born a twin automatically
made you less worthy of love and trust
but as if all of this weren't enough
already maki and might actually
also have to deal with real physical
consequences of being twins as well
their cursed powers
basically treated them as one person as
well so that mai ended up with a
uniquely strong cursed ability but
no combat skills whatsoever while maki
is one of the physically
most gifted characters in the story but
without so much as an
ounce of cursed energy which in the
largest family of due to sorcerers
basically made her the worst among the
worst as a result
both maki and mai grew up as outcasts of
the same family which
left them with nothing but each other to
really hold onto emotionally
long story short maki and mai basically
both
share the same fate of growing up abused
and neglected by a family
that only cares about power and yet
both of them deal with it in very
different ways and while the story
introduces us to maki as the mature
tough and straightforward twin mai is
presented as hateful
evil and childish
and yet this perception is purposefully
misleading
as you might remember from my analysis
of nobara as we learned throughout their
flashback
in the relationship of the twins maki is
actually the more hurtful one
her big desire in life is paying back
those who abused her and her sister
who she always used to protect as a
child and yet
in the process of struggling to get
stronger she forgets about her sister
completely
focusing fully on her goal mai on the
other hand
never wanted to become a sorcerer in the
first place she
never had maki's mental strength for
that all she wanted was having her big
sister by her side
the only family she ever had and yet
through maki's struggle for
power she herself had no other choice
but also become a sorcerer
or be left alone at the bottom of the
[Music]
clan
in addition probably in an effort to
protect mai from the consequences of
going against the zane clan maki
severs her ties with her sister
completely however
this hurts mai even more and while she
can finally find comrades at the kyoto
school
she never had maki's conviction power or
drive
as a result we hear mai echoing a lot of
the opinions and behaviors of the people
around her as she doesn't have the
confidence to form her own opinions and
forge her own path
basically she's just letting herself be
pulled along by the stream of events
around her and
the only way she now sees to get her
sister's attention
is by taunting her or those around her
the place where she
actually wants to be ken
the point here is that very much in the
spirit of being twins
maki and mai are one person split into
two both dealing with their abusive
family
in their own way and yet at the same
time both
being a side of the same coin mai is
insecure
weak willed averse to fighting emotional
but also has an extremely powerful
ability that allows her to create
matter from nothing
and even though she actually forms
friendships really fast
her whole life is determined by her
relationship with her sister
her fault as a character then fault from
a writing perspective of course
is relying on maki and making her
responsible for her own feelings
and events in her life mice arc then is
about finding her own determination to
fight back against the abuse and
oppression by her family and the juju
two worlds
side by side with her sister maki on the
other hand
is strong a fighter and just like gojo
thinks everything can be done and solved
by strength alone
strength surely is important in the
jewish world marky has internalized a
very unhealthy view of strength
not showing any weakness as a result
maki blocks out her own emotions and
insecurities
completely focusing mostly on herself
similar to gojo she acknowledges the
value of having strong companions and
being able to fight together but in the
end her philosophy
is this
it's not that maki is a hateful person
it's that she's conditioned
not to accept any kind of love because
she was never
shown the unconditional love of a family
that she was owed she's so busy trying
to reject
everything that the zane clan stands for
that she can't really accept
other people's feelings at all positive
or negative
she's too busy thinking about herself
protecting herself
trying not to hate herself and so she
can't receive
mice feelings again i think it's really
easy to draw parallel to megumi here
who's not even blood related to his
sister
but does everything he can for his only
real family member
desperately wanting to talk to her
maki on the other hand who has the
chance to talk to her own twin sister
and
only real family in this world whenever
she wants
doesn't her having to wear glasses
because she otherwise is blind to curses
is really symbolic here because these
glasses
also represent her inability to see
other people for
who they are i think if you watched my
gojo video you will
recognize a pattern here
as a result maki's character arc is all
about understanding that strength
isn't always the answer and that forming
real relationships with others
especially her own sister is an
essential part of living a good life
and this also includes acknowledging and
accepting her sister's feelings and
wishes
into her heart and while her justified
hatred toward a family is a powerful
drive for her growth as a sorcerer
at some point after dealing with the
saiyan clan
she will need a more healthy goal in
life that is not defined by violence and
hate but that
actually will do good in the world or
sink
into deeper darkness as members of the
zayn family
sometimes tend to do zayn
one thing however is for certain maki
already being as strong as she is with
mai by her side once again becoming one
whole
she will be a force to be reckoned with
within the jewish world
and no one should underestimate her
power and role in the story
oh yeah sorry coming up next pure evil
why mahito is creeping you the [ __ ] out
go watch it here or any of these other
videos
thanks for watching peace